are you looking to pick up pokken  tournament if you have a shelf full of  amiibo then the Pokemon fighting game  will put them all to good use every  single amiibo is compatible with the  game seriously we don't know exactly  what the collectible figures will do  Nintendo's website only says that they  unlock in-game items so whether that  means costumes consumable items or  characters we'll have to wait and see I  just want to know how Pokemon will react  to my shovelknight amiibo what can't  ornament releases for Wii U on March  18th alongside a special controller if  Nintendo has more to say about amia but  before then you'll hear about it from us  and for all the Pokemon news you need  you're already in the right place